ماشيه على الاقدام ولمسافات طويله احيانا
تحت القصف ووسط الجثث وبين الدبابات يغادر
السودانيون الخرطوم مدينه تحت النار
والعنف الى اجل غير مسمى الفرار لكثيرين
كان خيارا بين المر والامر اما البقاء في
مناطق لا تعرف الاشتباكات فيها هدنه منذ
السبت الدامي او الهروب وسط خشيه تعرض
المنازل للنهب والقص الوصول الى ولايه
اكثر امنا ليس خاتمه الاحزان الوطن كله
بحسابات السياسه وفوض السلاح في ازمه قد
تكون الاخطر في تاريخه الحديث التغريبه
السودانيه بدات فعلا استنادا للامم
المتحده ما بين عشره الاف وعشرين الف شخص
فروا من البلد الى الجاره تشاد في عاصمه
بنيتها التحتيه متهالكه في الايام العاديه
هي الان مسرح مفتوح على كل الازمات
الانسانيه بتفاصيلها المؤلمه جدا
والمستمره مع كل هدنه تخترق في دقائقها
الاولى من سيء الى اسوا تصف التقارير
المحليه والدوليه اوضاع المستشفيات
المؤسسات الطبيه في البلد بحاجه الى من
يسعفها بشكل مرعب يرتفع اعداد المرضى
والمصابين المدنيين الذين يموتون بسبب
غياب العلاج اعلنت نقابه الاطباء
السودانيين ارتفاع عدد المستشفيات
المتوقفه كليا عن الخدمه الى 52 من اصل 74
في العاصمه الخرطوم والولايات الاخرى التي
تكتوي بنار المواجهات المسلحه اضافت
النقابه ان تسعه من المستشفيات التي اعلنت
خارج الخدمه كانت قد تعرضت للقص وبان 19
مستشفى اخليت بشكل قصري مستشفيات في وسط
الخرطوم مهدده بالتوقف عن العمل نظرا الى
نقص الامدادات والكوادر الطبيه
المسلحون بهم صمم منذ السبت الماضي عن
عشرات نداءات الاستغاثه من الداخل والخارج
لتوفير ممرات انسانيه للمدنيين وندعو جميع
الاطراف الى تنفيذ توقف انساني مستدام في
اقرب وقت ممكن لكي يتمكن اولئك المحاصرون
بسبب القتال من البحث عن الملف
[تصفيق]
لسقفه ولا جدار في الخرطوم يستطيع في هذه
الايام العصيبه ان يكون عازلا لرصاص
يتطاير في السماء مثل عاصفه رمليه استنفذ
عمال الاغاثه كل المفردات لوصفه رشيديا
التي يعيشها الناس قال المتحدث باسم
الهلال الاحمر السوداني ان المستشفيات
منهاره تماما وخاليه من كل المستلزمات
الوضع اكثر من كارثي الخرطوم الامنه حتى
في اوج الحروب التي شهدتها ولايات في
السودان خسرت هذا الوصف في صراع اسكن
الرعب في قلوب الملايين اقتتال سيحرم
السودانيين مما بقي من فرحه العيد في وطن
لم تترك الماتم والمااسف مكانا سوى للحزن
والخشيه من ان يطول هذا الكابوس